I
talked about the scientists I talked
about Trump I talked about Biden we've
we've got to get to one other candidate
for president who has just announced his
run
he's not getting nearly enough coverage
even though the announcement came
yesterday classic lame stream media
doesn't want to cover the real
candidates that person of course would
be
Joe exotic
yes the Tiger King who is currently in
prison
for uh hiring a Hitman to kill his
Nemesis Carol Baskin
Joe exotic
is declared that he is running as a
Republican
for president
in his announcement he said put aside
that I am gay that I am in prison for
now that I used drugs in the past that I
had more than one boyfriend at once and
that Carol hates my guts
this all has not a thing to do with me
being able to be your voice
the best thing you have going for
supporting me is that I am used to
fighting my whole life just to get by I
am broke they have taken everything I
ever worked for away and it's time we
take this country back
now
Joe has a couple of points elsewhere in
his announcement he said I'm just in
prison because of the corruption of the
justice department and I don't think
that's true I think he's in prison
because he hired a hit man to kill a
lady
but his point is that justice department
is corrupt
even at uh Whitaker the former acting uh
attorney general who said that there is
a two-tiered system of justice in the
United States
we know that the justice department goes
hard after pro-life grannies and goes
hard after horn-headed people being
given a private tour by police around
the capitol on January 6th taking
selfies but they allowed BLM off the
hook we know that that's true
we know that people can change America
is the place of Second Chances and we
know that candidates who have nothing to
lose or sometimes the very best
candidates
this is one of the arguments for Trump
actually is they've thrown everything at
them they've taken away everything of
his that they can
short of throwing them in prison and so
he's not he's not really beholden to
anybody that's true
that said it would appear that Joe
Exotic is basically unrepentant uh I I'm
not sure that he's really reformed any
of his ways at all and so I will not
I will I don't I don't want to endorse
in the primaries but I don't think that
I will be supporting Joe Exotic for his
run though he can run and presidential
candidates have run before from prison
Eugene Debs famously a socialist ran
from prison and he got something like
eight percent of the vote so don't if
you're in it you can win it don't write
any candidate out including Joe exotic
the country at the moment is in pretty
clear decline on pretty much every front
this would explain why the country is
turning inward on the foreign policy
front
why at least the opposition in this
country which is the conservatives why
why we're turning inward
and it's not just the isolationist
Fringe of the right wing
it's even one of the leading Republican
presidential candidates for 2024 that
would be Ron DeSantis who has turned his
vision inward when it comes to the war
in Ukraine uh he just told Tucker
Carlson quote
well the U.S has many vital national
interests becoming further entangled in
a territorial dispute between Ukraine
and Russia is not one of them so the
squishes and the libs and the neocons
and the whatever term you want to use
for the more Centrist liberal
establishment wing of the party they are
furious at Ron DeSantis for saying you
know I don't think we need to write a
blank check to Ukraine and
some of the more conservative Maga
right-wing people in the Republican
party they don't believe him because not
that long ago Ron DeSantis was
advocating for more intervention in
Ukraine you're better off dealing with
Putin by being strong I mean we've tried
to deal with some of this in the
Congress a couple years ago we
authorized lethal aid for Ukraine so
that they could resist some of the
Russian incursion the Obama
Administration fought us on that but I
think that's the type of thing when when
Putin sees he can gain an inch he's
acted apt to take a mile and basically
if America is not going to give him any
pushback I think he's going to continue
to try to expand Russian influence okay
so from the pro Trump camp this is one
of the clips that says that that they
insist proves that DeSantis isn't for
real he's blown in the wind and we can't
really trust him to execute the America
First agenda but but this is Complicated
by the fact that President Trump
previously had also argued for greater
involvement in Ukraine
remember that with Ukraine I sent the
javelins that you see are so effective
against the tanks Biden didn't and in
fact he ended our last order probably
it'll get there because everyone
realized it was the right thing to do
and Obama remember Obama Biden they sent
blankets I send javelins and they said
well you know what the Japanese are the
anti-tank weapons they knock the hell
out of those tanks
and Ukraine wouldn't be having a chance
without him that was all sent by me all
of it we sent other military equipment
too we didn't send our soldiers but we
sent them a lot of equipment okay and he
makes a distinction there he says we're
not sending soldiers but we sent him a
lot of equipment we've we've been
funding the Ukraine war effort so what
does this mean it means that Trump and
DeSantis are running in the same Lane
and they've
both taken all sorts of contradictory
positions over the years
now president Trump is very anti-free
trade he's very pro-tariff there were
op-ed there was one op-ed in particular
that I'm thinking of that was published
in his name when he was considering
running for president first time and it
was a very pro-free trade Pro
globalization sort of op-ed obviously he
became much more protectionist and and
now advocates for a type of mercantilism
there are also videos of of Ron DeSantis
saying I'm very pro-free trade he took
votes that were pro-free trade now it
would appear he's making a little turn
so what does this mean it means that
both these guys are running in the same
Lane
there for the rest of the campaign they
will both be trying to run in the same
Lane
Trump is going to say I'm Trump I'm one
of a kind I'm an American original I'm
the guy who changed the Republican party
I've done it before I'll do it again Ron
DeSantis is going to say president Trump
had his time he didn't win re-election
he's undisciplined and so I'm Trump
without the baggage but I'm I'm going to
be a type of trump I'm just going to be
the the new and improved version of
trump they're both running in the same
Lane so the question for primary voters
I don't think is going to be parsing
different issues I doubt that there's
going to be much daylight at all on any
of these issues I suspect the question
is going to come down to who do you
trust more to do it so right now Ronda
Santos after some bad news in recent
weeks in the polls with President Trump
taking his lead back DeSantis not really
growing in the polls according to a CNN
SSRS poll
DeSantis is now at top of the Republican
primary field 39 to Trump's 37 so
essentially tied Haley's at seven Pence
is at six Tim Scott's at two so noon
news at two junkan is even in the poll
he's at one percent
uh so it remains anybody's race the
national polls don't really matter when
it comes to presidential primaries
because because the primaries happen
state by state so what matters is who's
a lady in Iowa who's leading in New
Hampshire who's leading in South
Carolina who's leading in Florida
because as momentum builds that's how
you're going to see the the the real
hierarchy of candidates begin to shape
up it won't happen for a while but
according to another poll more than
one-third of Biden voters do not want
him to run again and so you can expect
more Republican candidates and all sorts
of different Lanes you're going to have
the Centrist Lane you're going to have
the neocon lane you're going to have the
libertarian Lane and you're gonna have
the Trump Lane and right now you got two
candidates running in that lane the rest
of the show continues now you do not
want to miss it
uh you can become a member right now at
dailywire.com using promo code Knowles
at checkout you will get two months free
on all annual plans Mr Davies has lots
of secret special fun things planned for
the climber.com inner circle of the
members block we'll see you over there
[Music]